IT REPORTS FROM A FROZEN CHICAGO
TONIGHT WHERE THE COLD IS
DEFINITELY TAKING HOLD.
>> WISCONSIN, MICHIGAN, AND
ILLINOIS ARE UNDER STATES OF
EMERGENCY, GIVING GOVERNORS THE
POWER TO ACTIVATE THE
NATIONAL GUARD IN ADVANCE OF
POSSIBLY RECORD-SETTING COLD
DESCENDING ON THE NORTH AND
CENTRAL UNITED STATES, WITH THE
CITIES LIKE CHICAGO SET TO BE
THE EPICENTER OF THIS
LIFE-THREATENING WEATHER EVENT.
>> THE TEMPERATURES TODAY,
TOMORROW, THURSDAY ARE NOT TO BE
TAKEN LIGHTLY.
THESE ARE ACTUALLY A PUBLIC
HEALTH RISK.
>> A PARTICULAR RISK IN THIS
BRUTAL COLD IS THE HOMELESS
POPULATION.
OUT OF TENT CITY JUST SOUTHWEST
OF CHICAGO SLOOP, GOVERNOR SAYS
HE WILL NOT TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE WARMING BUSES OR WARMING
CENTERS THE CITY HAS MADE
AVAILABLE.
HE WILL STAY IN HIS TENT.
>> IT IS CROWDED, MOST OF THE
TIME THEY'VE GOT BUGS.
>> WINS THAT HOLD POCKETS OF
ARCTIC AIR HAVE DESTABILIZED,
ALLOWING THE SUPER COOL AIR TO
SLIP SOUTH D UNITED STATES.
THE RESULT?
TEMPERATURES ARE PREDICTED TO
DROP INTO THE NEGATIVE 20s,
WIND ACCOMPANYING THE WEATHER
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO CREATE
WINDSHIELDS OF NEGATIVE 50,
NEGATIVE 60 DEGREES.
ENOUGH TO ALLOW FROSTBITE TO
SAID AND IN A MATTER OF MINUTES.
>> IT PUTS CITIZENS AT RISK FROM
THE COLD, THEIR HEARTS STOPPING
BECAUSE THEIR BODY GETS SO COLD,
THAT KIND OF A PROBLEM.
>> NATIONWIDE, MORE THAN 1700
FLIGHTS WERE CANCELED, 8,000
DELAY DUE TO THE WEATHER.
WHEN TEMPERATURES DROP BELOW 0,
SALT AND CHEMICALS THAT MELT
ROAD ICE ARE NO LONGER
EFFECTIVE, SO EVEN AFTER
PLOWING, ROADS ARE EXPECTED TO
BE ICY AND DANGEROUS.
ROAD CREWS ARE ACTIVATED AS FAR
SOUTH AS GEORGIA WHERE THE
WEATHER IS EXPECTED TO REACH
BEARD ALSO WHERE THE SUPER BOWL
IS BEING
PLAYED ON SUNDAY.
>> IT IS OBVIOUSLY VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE IN TOWN
THIS WEEK.
WE WANT TO KEEP THEM SAFE.
>> CHICAGO IS NOW UNDER A
WINDCHILL ADVISORY THAT WILL
TRANSFER TO A WARNING AT THE END
OF THIS BROADCAST, MEANING
LIFE-THREATENING CONDITIONS ARE
IMMINENT.